David without any further ado why don't
you present your case sure well thanks
for having me first of all I think that
there's a couple different things that I
find sort of most interesting about
what's going on right now that I find to
be sort of encompassed primarily right
now by Robert Moeller's investigation
but really that goes beyond that as well
into sort of patterns involving Donald
Trump and his associates both during the
campaign and during the current
administration so I think that there's
sort of like a three pronged approach to
take here and you know to be super clear
I'm of course willing to have my mind
changed on on any of these things and I
I think that really figuring out my
ultimate goal is really just to figure
out what did happen what didn't happen
and most importantly were any crimes
committed so I think that to start with
the catalyst for what is now known as
Robert Moeller's special investigation
was the possibility that Donald Trump or
people involved with his campaign or
administration quote colluded with
Russia or individuals associated with
the Russian government in ways that
might have been illegal now we don't yet
know whether that did or didn't happen
and I don't I don't pretend that we know
but what I sort of focused on at this
point because again there's an
investigation going on right so we we
will by definition we don't know or at
least I hope we don't know everything
that Robert Muller knows there's a
couple different things to think about
number one is there's been a lot of
focus on the law not using the word
collusion and we've seen the narrative
shift from there was no collusion to
collusion isn't actually a crime and I
think that that's sort of a semantic
argument that's not really relevant here
right so I think that if we want to talk
about prong one which is quote collusion
we really need to think about well where
things are valued solicited implicitly
or explicitly from foreign nationals for
example in connection with with
elections if there's things of value
that have been solicited or that the
Trump administration was
interested in accepting that may be a
crime and again there's an investigation
going on we're gonna have to wait and I
think when we look at Donald Trump jr.
being offered quote dirt on Hillary and
responding if it's what you say I love
it especially later in the summer that
is certainly an openness to accept
materials of value from foreign
nationals and initially we were told
that the lawyer in question Natalia
vessel mats kaya has no connection to
the Kremlin we've since found out that
actually dating back many years she was
working with the Kremlin including on a
defense of a fraud case against the
Russian company and more recently
admitting that she was actually
reporting to a Russian government
official so there we basically have
effectively colloquially Donald Trump
jr. soliciting opposition research from
a foreign national for which there is
value opposition research something that
costs a lot of money we know that
because how much money Cambridge
analytical was paid for the work that
they were doing so that's an offer that
was clearly from someone that would be a
foreign national under the law it was
about Hillary Clinton meaning it's about
a US election so that that would be if
we want to talk about quote collusion
that's something I would look at pretty
directly in addition the other element I
think is important is that there was at
least the implied offer from Donald
Trump jr. to help work on a repeal of
the Magnitsky Act which put sanctions on
Russia that would be a quid pro quo and
again I'm not a lawyer we don't know
what Robert Muller knows but I've spoken
to lawyers who say that that also
escalates the the potential criminality
just as one more sort of element and
there's lots of these for this this
possible coordination we know that Trump
campaign advisor George papadopolis did
meet with a Russian agent who also said
he has dirt on Hillary Clinton later
bragged about Russia getting damaging
Clinton emails lied to the FBI about
contacts with Russia so while we will
not really know the full scope of
so-called collusion and I don't pretend
to know I think that there is more than
enough circumstantial evidence that this
should be in
negation and that's what I support right
I'm not making any claims about my
knowledge of specific crimes that didn't
happen but what I am saying is that
anyone who denies that the
circumstantial evidence warrants this
investigation I I disagree with however
then there's sort of like two other
prongs
there's the prong of whether there was
any criminality an attempt made to end
this investigation and once again this
is an ongoing investigation that's going
on were firings that took place possibly
crossing the line into criminal were
there conversations that took place that
could be considered witness tampering
and I present these once again as
questions because by definition this is
an ongoing investigation and this is why
I have a problem with the sort of
absolutist denialist who say their
definitive definitively were no crimes
period because we don't know that all we
have is the circumstantial information
which I would argue more than justifies
the investigation that's going on and
I'm glad to sort of delve more into the
the obstruction side of the conversation
and in the interest of sort of getting
to the third prong here there is no
doubt that it's legally well within
Robert Muller scope to explore any
possible crimes that he and his
investigators suspect may have been
committed as a result of the
investigation into both potential quote
collusion and obstruction and I I think
that there's no doubt at this point that
money-laundering is a very very high
probability when you look at a number of
different deals involving many many
different countries including countries
in the Middle East including Russia and
Russian individuals as well through
condo purchases potentially with
inflated values and whether that is part
of the Russia story or not sort of
depends on where you draw the line but
certainly there's no doubt that those
concerns for the Moller team have
stemmed from their initial investigation
and to sort of put a final point on it
and then I'm obviously super curious to
hear Ray's perspective on this I think
that a lot of what is going on
is self-inflicted by Donald Trump in the
sense that if from day one if the first
time that anything about Russia is
mentioned Donald Trump doesn't tweet
about it says simply I support the full
investigation I know I will be
vindicated and in the meantime I'm going
to work on my political agenda I think
anywhere from seventy to ninety percent
of what's going on now never happens and
it's been self-inflicted wound after
self-inflicted wound carried out by the
president so that's the the sort of
general overview of my position all
right thank you very much David Ray it's
your turn to talk to us for a few
minutes so the floor is yours well I
have to agree with David about
self-inflicted wounds on the part of
Donald Trump I mean you couldn't have a
worse a worst character to heap scorn on
himself he lies all the time
the question is what happened with
respect to Russian meddling so to speak
in the 2016 election and that's what
we're dealing with here we're not
dealing with whether these guys are
crooks I mean you have to be blind or
deaf and not to realize that you're
dealing with bunch of crooks
money laundry as the name of the game
what are they doing with manna fort well
they've got the book on writer fort and
so they say look metaphor you know we
can we can push your way for thirty five
years
um don't you remember doctor remember
Trump telling you about collusion with
with Russia if you could just remember
that oh yes think about if you could
remember that yeah bro we could probably
get you off with the six months
suspended sentence that's the way Muller
works the record is very clear when we
talk about crooks he's one of them it's
always call me so let me just backtrack
for a second and refer to the fact that
I've been watching Russian leaders for
over a half a century actually
fifty-five years it's almost exactly 55
years since I joined the CIA
an analyst of Soviet foreign policy so
watch Russian leaders look at the world
very very close way and when I think
about the 206 2016 election now here is
pushing or watching the campaign and
said his advisers around reducing oh my
god this Trump Wow what a character
he's unpredictable he brags about being
predictable and he lashes out at the
slightest slight whether it's real or
imagined oh man this is gonna be really
fun
this is just the guy I want to have with
his fingers on the nuclear codes I do
all we can to help them help them win
now if that sounds ridiculous it's
because it is ridiculous there is no no
suggestion in Russian statements or
Russian TV shows and I have people
watching this very closely to suggest
that there was a preference that there
was a preference to Donald for Donald
Trump
of a Hillary Clinton that's pretty much
the basic premise here now a sub subset
here is that quote everyone knew Hillary
Clinton would win
okay now Comey says that in his book I
call me explains that he felt he could
do the things he did which many of which
were clearly illegal clearly
unconstitutional because he was as he
put it he was it operating in an
environment where Hillary was going to
win and so what Hillary wins you know
who's gonna hold him to account for
taking wild liberties with the law and
the Constitution so no just to put it
into this point if Hillary is gonna win
if the New York Times had it 83%
that she was gonna win on the morning of
the election you're mr. poutine right
and you're sitting back there anything
my god uh everybody thinks he'll are you
gonna win but you know I think just for
fun yeah yeah that's what I think I'll
go I'll miss you
the DNC of the Democratic National
Committee computers and so I can find
you know she'll follow she'll find it
out and I won't be good for you should
be remorse toward me then but let's just
for fun
yeah suddenly give me a break there was
no percentage in poutine messing around
and the Democratic National Committee
computers so what do we have here we
have any evidence well no we don't all
we have his claims by corrupt people
working for the Democratic National
Committee and I have to say that what
David talked about opposition research
well yeah neglected to mention that
Hillary Clinton and the DNC played mega
paid mega bucks through a cutout to have
an ex UK spy do quote opposition
research turning up scurrilous detail
that even Comey admitted was scurrilous
about Trump cavorting with prostitutes
in Moscow well before he ever became a
candidate and you know it really is is
not quite right to talk about opposition
research without talking about both
sides so what we have here is a
situation where well I'll just I'll just
mention one other thing it's not widely
known we veteran intelligence
professionals for sanity will include by
the way too formal former technical
directors from the National Security
Agency the NSA we asked Obama formally
and a memorandum before he left office
would you please would you please make
clear what evidence there is that a the
russians hacked in to the DNC and be
they gave it to to WikiLeaks okay now it
turns out that what Obama said on the
18th of January just before two days
before he left office he said you know
the Russian heck so to speak in quotes
for my purposes
we don't know how it got the wiki leaks
at these conclusive results namely and
that NSA FBI CIA memorandum turned out
to be quote inconclusive in quote
Obama's words the other thing I'll just
mention is that in this spurious
memorandum which is an embarrassment to
intelligence analysis that I've been
with this problem 50 years the one that
they gave to to the president-elect of
the 6th of January there's a sort of a
left-handed compliment to WikiLeaks can
what they say is the reason the Russian
tank was given to WikiLeaks is because
of their of their reputation I'm not
fooling around with the information for
not shading it anyway but just putting
it out as is whoa so there's it there's
a reality here Julian Assange has never
ever been successfully criticized for
having molded or shaped or fixed what he
puts out it was all the real deal and
the last thing I'll say is what was the
real deal the real deal was the
Democratic National Committee documents
the emails that Julian Assange
advertised that he had on the 12th of
June 2016 and which he released in a
readily searchable manner on the 22nd of
July just three days before the
Democratic National Convention and what
did they say well people need to know
that what they said was that Hillary
Clinton stole the election from Bernie
Sanders it's pure it's pure that's give
me you know if you don't believe me why
did the white get the top five officials
of the National Democratic National
Committee quit on the spot okay that was
three days before the election okay
that's pretty embarrassing but what
happened
well groundwork had had already been
laid to divert attention and what was in
those emails to later the rush into it
why did the rush into it why would a
white arrest now even Hillary Clinton's
PR person Jennifer
Gary admitted but that was a really hard
sell a really hard sell until until we
got back to Brooklyn and what is
Jennifer Palmieri say then he says well
then we got intelligence people and
correspondents journalists in touch with
intelligence people and they gave us
they gave us the material about Russian
colluding with Russian and then the
Obama administration started I started
confirming that then we were off and
running and so that's that I heard this
personally from Jennifer Palmieri right
after the election so the whole thing
was prepared what what the situation
here is I would like to drive home is
that Russian collusion was initially
prepared as a magnificent distraction I
remember the movie magnificent obsession
well this is a magnificent distraction
what was in those emails and was in
those emails showed that Hillary stole
the nomination for Bernie Sanders so if
you're going to look at you know why why
we have this in my view of the worst
president the United States has ever had
in office you know you can lay that at
Hillary Clinton because had she not had
she not stolen the nomination for me
Sanders we would be looking at that
president Bernie Sanders now we would
not be looking at the terrible situation
both domestically and abroad
so you know don't blame the Russians for
God's sake without any evidence blame
Hillary Clinton all right ray thank you
very much David you have I don't know
reasonable amount how doesn't say three
minutes but there's no clock running a
reasonable amount of time to respond to
what ray just said yeah so listen it's
difficult in a sense to respond to what
Ray said because it has very very little
to do with any of what's actually going
on with Russia so let's see if I can
just look at a few of the points that
Ray made and a lot of these points I'm
having sort of a little bit of trouble
parsing the narrative because these
there were a lot of things that are just
kind of all over the place so first and
foremost ray
talked about the DNC primary being
rigged against Bernie Sanders and for
Hillary Clinton I I agree with him I
reported on that extensively I voted for
Bernie Sanders I don't know if Bernie
Sanders would have defeated Donald Trump
in a general election race it would have
been a different race but it has no
bearing whatsoever on for example the
Trump Tower meeting and its legality so
that's first and foremost the idea that
there is no sort of chain of custody of
hacked information between Russian
actors and the Trump campaign is just
patently untrue right we have extensive
reporting about the direct connection
between both Roger stone a Trump advisor
and Donald Trump jr.
and WikiLeaks Julian Assange we have
learned a great deal about the
intermediary between the hacker known as
gusoff err gucchy 42.0 and WikiLeaks and
we have extensive information about the
actions of that hacker who tried to
present himself as a Romanian individual
but indeed was actually a Russian
individual but again it has no actual
bearing on for example whether the Trump
Tower meeting was illegal ray also
mentioned that hey listen if you're
gonna talk about opposition research
which I did you also have to talk about
the fact that Hillary Clinton also
bought opposition research whether
Hillary Clinton also it opposition
research has no bearing whatsoever on
whether the Trump Tower meeting was
illegal or whether the firings that took
place to end the investigation by robert
muller constitute obstruction of justice
ray also talked about fired FBI director
James Comey and whether James Comey did
or didn't act in good faith it's a great
conversation to have it's one that I'm
I'm open to having but whether James
Comey did or didn't act in good faith is
simply not an argument that relates to
what the Trump campaign objectively did
and ray started his presentation by
saying that Russian leaders who he's
been following for a very very long time
have always tried to sow chaos in
Western democracies
that's absolutely true if you look at
Alexander
Dugan's book the foundations of
geopolitics from 1997 you see that this
has been the Russian mo for a very long
time but again it is simply not an
argument that negates or refutes any of
the facts that I put forward so I think
that what Rey has brought up are all
interesting topics and relevant in a
certain context but they in no wait may
actually relate to what we're discussing
today and finally and then I'll turn
this over Tom the idea that the steel
dossier had only inaccuracies in it has
been widely debunked and every week we
learn about another element of that
dossier that has actually been confirmed
the Carter page trips to Moscow and
meetings with Russian officials my
Cancun's role in pursuing business
opportunities for Trump in Russia the
allegations that were initially denied
by Trump that he had spent several
nights in Moscow in 2013 around that
pageant which was initially completely
denied by Trump we now know from
airplane records that it's actually true
in other words every week another
element of the steel dossier is
confirmed to be true so I on the facts
that that Ray tried to assert to
contradict me I think he's wrong on the
fact and then most of what he said just
doesn't actually relate to the
discussion today all right ray now you
have several minutes to respond to David
sure let me just respond to some of
these points robert muller has a
reputation I won't go into that let's
talk about Kumi right now now the
celebrated charge is that Trump fired
Comey because he wanted to suppress the
investigation now what really happened
what really happened was on the 6th of
January 2017 the intelligence directors
went and briefed president-elect Trump
it was Comey it was John Brennan CIA was
Rogers from NSA and who's the other
person well it was yell clapper whose
it's about it's over all this stuff is
National Intelligence director now Comey
has made it clear that he asked the
others to leave after they had briefed
him on this as I say the worst piece of
intelligence analysis fact and evidence
impoverished which said that poutine
really wanted Trump to win and
interfered after they had briefed them
on that then Comey says by his own
admission that he raised the the the
urination tapes the the business about
now this is how it happens by the way in
Washington when a new president comes in
the head of the FBI says now mr.
president-elect we do it this is pretty
scarless stuff ahead in a week we can't
really well it's not confirmed but you
should know you should know that we have
these we have this information okay and
the press has it too and so you know if
you just know that that they say that
you did a a B and C now this is an old
tactic as I say with no presidents by
the deep state represented in this case
by combing
now if I were Trump I would fired it
call me on the spot I said don't bring
me any unconfessed sin firm ation and
try to intimidate me by saying that
you've got this stuff and I should know
about it you're fired
instead he waited awhile now when he did
fire Comey he admitted to somebody it's
one of the TV personalities yeah I got
fired him because of this Russia thing
now that was widely interpreted as his
admission that he wanted to suppress
this Russian investigation wasn't that
it was they call me was trying to
intimidate the president trying to get a
lever over him by saying look we got
this stuff here we confirm it already I
would have fired him on the spot what
you know how does this thing plays out
another thing I agree with David on this
is that we have to let Muller continue
to play but meanwhile they have been
some revelations which need to be
addressed let me
lucifer 2.0 david says he was a russian
david this gonna shock you but lucifer
2.0 was john brennan
of the CIA and we can prove it do you
know about well i want to ask you
there is a bevy of documents released in
march of this year
coming directly from the CIA no one
disputes his authenticity it was given
by an insider probably a contractor
julia the son started publishing them in
march now what today would they talk
about they talk about cyber tools that
are in the ocean all that CIA deploys
with the help of the NSA which are the
real experts i one for example allowed
allowed whoever wanted to do it to take
control of a car and make it go 110
miles an hour and get and get the person
killed in the car another one allowed
people to snoop through a TV that was
ostensibly off but was on recording
everything in your bedroom but those
were small potatoes on the 31st of march
and david you can be forgiven for not
knowing about this because the new york
times washing the wall street journal'
they all all check with the CIA and said
well can we print this and say no no no
don't put this what did that say it was
called this tool was called marble
framework you know what did it work in
well worked in five languages Chinese
Persian Korean Arabic and question okay
Cyrillic now what's the point here
the point here is that this tool
according to the CIA document was
designed to hack into other computers
and other computer systems and quote up
Foose Kate end quote who attacked in and
leave telltale signs in like ooh
Cyrillic Russian and other places and so
that they can attribute it misattributed
to somebody else now bill Binney who
knows a lot more about this kind of
technology than I do
his previous technical director than si
he tells me and it's very likely that
the celebrated hack which was done on
superimposed on Russian ms word
equivalent templates and included the
name of the first head of the forerunner
of the KGB in Russia that that clearly
was not done by some weird mistake by
the Russian intelligence services that
most likely was done by this cyber tool
inventory that the CIA has and that it
has deployed so you know don't tell me
about guseva 2.0 unless you really have
looked into it we have looked into it
the only the only outfit that claims
this kind of thing is an outfit called
CrowdStrike that's run pretty much by
DNC people by the Atlantic Council
people these are the people who looked
into the so-called hack the hack that
was described by John McCain as an act
of war described by John Bolton as a
true act of war but they call me do what
did call me dude well he didn't ask
or he didn't secure the proper warrant
to look at the DNC computers now it's
kind of embarrassing act of war and so
he's asked about this at Congress in the
Senate and they said no that director
Comey um why is it that that you didn't
seize those computers or at least
injured people then look at the you know
how the heck happened and he squirmed
then he said well I concede I can see
that that's best practice you should
actually have a physical a physical
access to computers but but there was a
first-rate first-rate cyber team that
was working on it first-rate give me a
break
CrowdStrike is as crooked as they come
so you know the last thing I'll say here
is that you can be forgiven David
because you get a lot of your
information from the New York Times now
I'm from the New York
my parents wouldn't go to bed at night
without reading the New York Times
through and through if they fell asleep
they put it in a special place and
they'd read that former days edition
before they'd even open the new one New
York Times used to be all the news that
prints fits that was fit to print almost
but no longer and that's the real core
here when I was still in active duty at
the CIA there was a fellow named William
Casey came in under Ronald Reagan and at
the first White House meeting announced
to not only Reagan but the other cabinet
level officials this quote will know
that our disinformation is complete when
everything the American people believes
is false
period end quote that's where we are now
how do I know that from someone who is
there
Barbara Honegger and she she gave it to
one of the correspondence it was
published but you know I'm just sort of
like on page b-17 that's the deal here
what's your if you depending on the New
York Times The Washington Post The Wall
Street Journal you were not hearing
anything about for example how the the
House Intelligence Committee has come up
with a year-long investigation the the
outcome of which is to dispute this
notion that there's any evidence of the
major premise the major premise being
that pucchin preferred trump and
therefore sent his minions in to attack
the cyber system of the DNC and so forth
so you know it's really a really
unfortunate because I've never seen it
quite this bad and it's not you know
incidental you know we're talking about
the other nuclear-powered country and as
long as hysteria is whipped up with no I
repeat no provable evidence then you
know this is very dangerous because
people are being conditioned just as
they were before the war in Iraq to
believe that poutine is the equivalent
of Saddam Hussein that we have to do
something about it
alright ray thank you very much
but now is the part of our debate here
where you can ask ray any direct
question you would like to ask him and
then ray will have an opportunity to ask
you a question
yeah I mean listen Tom I I apologize but
I'm really struggling here to follow the
thread and there were just so many
missed statements and allusions to
conspiracy theories by Ray that I just I
don't I'm not in really I would be in a
position to sort of follow up with some
of my concerns about what he said but
we're so far off the path here that I
don't even know how I would put together
one question for for Ray at this point
would I be allowed instead to maybe just
respond to a few of the things that Ray
said if you'd prefer to do that that's
fine but then Ray will be able to ask
you whatever he wants but if that's what
you'd prefer that's totally fine I mean
listen ray insisted in that last bit of
talking about James Comey he claimed
that it's simply not true that Trump
fired Comey to suppress the
investigation Trump admitted that that's
why he fired Comey on national
television to Lester Holt right so the
the premise would be that Trump lied
when he admitted what his motives were I
would be curious as to why like in other
words it's bad enough to admit to that
if you're going to falsely admit to that
there must be something even worse that
is making you admit to something like
that
Ray called into question the urination
tape element of the dossier I think in
an attempt to discredit the entire thing
but as I said I've already listed to you
multiple elements of it that have been
confirmed so it's simply done an
argument to say that because the
urination tapes that are yet as
confirmed that there's nothing true in
the dossier you know I I don't know that
I'm prepared at this point to really get
into a full discussion about the deep
state that Ray referred to but that's
typically you know that that's not a
direction I'm I'm really comfortable
going in at this point simply because I
think that it's a total distraction and
red herring
the idea that gusoff er 2.0 is former
CIA director John Brennan I've seen no
evidence of that whatsoever and I would
by Trey to present evidence that he has
of that and I am willing to have my mind
change but I think it's a completely
spurious allegation and then you know
big bigger picture I just am NOT
following the argument that that ray is
making here that rebuts any of what I
said and and so with that said I'm glad
to have ray asked me any any question he
wants but I'm really struggling here
time okay we'll listen I'll give ray ray
you have two minutes to respond will
take that as like a question you have
two minutes just to respond to that and
then give David a question okay
conspiracy theorist now this is the way
people dismiss the reality first time I
was used by Allen Dulles where Allen
Dulles ran the Warren Commission looking
into the assassination of John Kennedy
when people said hey how can you do this
CIA may have been involved which it was
demonstrable involved he south
conspiracy theory conspiracy theory
conspiracy theory and that's used to
dismiss reality now this business about
they would saying that it's well known
that - Lester Holt President Trump
admitted according to David that it was
to suppress the the investigation you
know David words are really important
you have to go back and look at what
President Trump saying he said and I
quote because of this Russian thing and
quote now I think he'll have to admit
that's ambiguous at best but I think
that the Russian thing was Muller's
determination with the rest of these
people to discredit Trump to say that he
is falsely elected because the Russians
helped and that's very clear it was
because of the Russian thing but not the
Russian thing to just suppress it
because of komak but because of commis
bent to do this other thing now confirms
the dossier come on give me a break
it hasn't been confirmed there's nothing
in that that has been confirmed deep
state well you know
look at the FBI texts look at the texts
between Peter struck and his lover
Lisa page they were they were
constructing a quote insurance policy
end quote
in case Trump won it's very clear so
it's not it's not a conspiracy theory
it's not something dreamed up now I can
understand why you don't know about
gusoff or - because you haven't read the
near because all you read is the New
York Times you probably don't even know
about vault 7 and the documents that
that that are true documents authentic
that Julian of science described as
being more revealing than all the
material that Edward Snowden brought out
into Hong Kong so I forgive you for not
knowing about that there is one brief
story in The Washington Post about it
the headline of which said whoa recent
revelation from vault 7 marble there
shows that blows the whistle on the
cover the that the CIA has been using to
hack into other systems so read that
please and see if you don't understand
why it could be and this is you know
this is as I say this is not factual as
that bill Binney usually is an i but
this is a very reasonable suspicion that
since there's no evidence zero of
Russian hacking that this celebrated
hack the one on July 5 2016 bears the
earmarks of the application of something
called vault 7 marble framework which
was developed by the CIA with great help
from the NSA and which program includes
700 million lines of code ok 700 million
now if you talk $25 aligned that's a lot
of money so let's leave it there it's
just that you know it's too bad we can't
speak from the same base of knowledge
because as I say great new trains is not
sufficient can you transition into your
question ok yeah let me just ask David
have you ever heard of vault 7 marble
framework
yes I have uh yeah okay what do you
think of it I think that it is wholly
unrelated to any of the case that I laid
out here today and I remain stunningly
sort of confused as to you know going
back to what I was thinking we were
going to discuss in what way does any of
this relate to the legality or
illegality of the Trump Tower meeting or
whether obstruction of justice took
place I guess that that's the part that
I'm missing the Trump Tower meeting was
set up by a music promoter on the false
and a false allegation that there would
be real dirt revealed in this thing the
Trump Tower meeting is nothing if the
Moller thought the Trump Tower meeting
meant something meant something he would
have focused on it Muller has hit a dry
well let's face it and now he circulated
49 questions 49 questions I mean listen
none of that is true that these are just
falsehoods the Muller did not circulate
any questions those 49 questions were
actually taken down by Trump's lawyer
Jay Sekulow
that were together he got worried from
they came from the special counsel there
those were questions formulated by
Donald Trump's lawyer as possible
questions that would be asked based on
the general topics that Robert Muller's
team communicated would be topics of
discussion if ever Donald Trump sits
down with Robert Mulder but that now ray
has already moved the goalposts he first
said that Robert Muller circulated 49
questions now he's saying the questions
came from something Robert Muller said
so very quickly you see Tom how a lot of
these assertions just are changed when I
just offer the most my new pushback now
David you just admitted that Trump's
lawyers met with Muller's lawyers modern
Oracle meeting or a phone call
all right well all right they talked
okay and Muller's lawyers gave Trump's
lawyers a very good idea which mullet
which
Trump's lawyers composed into 49
questions that Muller was interested in
asking is that correct
that's my understanding of well that's
what that look the New York Times says
that they say they have six six of
people to prove it and nobody has denied
it so that's how these forty nine
questions arose they have broad
questions they go into everything and
and and anything and they reflects to me
a very desperate attempt to get the
President to incriminate himself by
saying a wrong wrong fact that he
doesn't remember correctly and then yeah
that's the perjury trap nonsense like
the idea either go in and tell the truth
or not and say he doesn't remember if he
doesn't remember but the entire concept
of a quote perjury trap is not something
that's serious for discussion I thought
they used on the general what's his name
general the general who is national
security adviser that's what they used
on him see the interest rates how is
your assertion that the only reason
Michael Flynn got into trouble was not
because he genuinely did things that
were crimes but because of perjury trap
was set for him and he fell for it is
that is that really your argument here
that's not my argument those are the
cells David those are the facts okay
what he did in terms of consulting with
foreign leaders was completely what any
national security adviser incoming would
do what they did was they got him
through an intercepted conversation
which was unmasked and they said now did
you talk about sanctions and he said you
know no I didn't so that's lying to the
FBI so were they doing actually okay we
indict him okay and now we can get him
to talk about other things he knows and
the other things he knew were not
sufficiently incriminating so that none
of this Muller is waiting till the end
of the the year so that he can go right
through the election yet get this thing
percolating all that time and the Senate
Intelligence Committee thankfully has
the documents okay so if we wait and
we'll see what the Senate Intelligence
Committee to
after they read interview John Brennan
and the others I think will know a lot
more David and you oughta really look at
more than the New York Times all right
I'm confused just just two quick notes
okay earlier in the debate ray
criticized me for getting my news from
the New York Times and in his last
statement he told me that something is
unquestionably true because it was
reported by the New York Times that's a
New York five or six things and it's
confirmed by the administration then the
one other thing I don't understand is
earlier during the conversation ray said
he agreed with me that indeed the Robert
Moeller investigation should continue
should go forward and we should see
where it ends up but then he most
recently said that it's actually a
calculated political move to go through
the election presumably to impact it so
if that's what you believe about the
investigation why do you agree with me
that it should be allowed to continue
well because the cost of ending it would
be too politically volatile you know let
the thing go he's not gonna come up with
anything the house has been at it for a
whole year they've come up with the
decision that there was no meddling the
Senate what are they doing and so you
know let him go I mean let's keep doing
it it's a political game I don't give a
rat's patootie about how they go all I
want to point out how does that after a
year a guy like Muller with the assets
that he has and with his access to NSA
and other really sensitive sources if he
can't come up with anything better than
some some some Facebook operations then
yeah it's sort of embarrassing
I'd like to reassert control here if I
may all right because David let me start
I'm gonna ask each of you a question but
I'm gonna ask Ray a question and maybe
it's the kind of question that you would
want to have asked him for clarification
so Ray have there been any meetings that
you know of between Trump people and
Russian operatives or Russian officials
that give you any kind of pause
give me some claws sure yeah they don't
give me any evidence though
well let's flush that out a bit what do
you what is something that concerns you
and give me a specific example well I
think that the Trump jr. was stupid and
rising to the debate to meet with this
lawyer he was promised by some music
promoter as I recall that only had be
some dirt on Hillary Clinton and so he
should have said this is real look into
this thing and not so that gives me some
pause but you know we intelligence
analysts like detectives look at
evidence and that's crude molar actually
has been doing he's come up a cropper
he's come up with zero except for these
really extraneous things what the stormy
Daniels have to do with collusion
between Trump and the Russia's what do
not this man afford what does the fact
that Trump well before anyone suspected
he would be a presidential candidate
fool around with money laundering or
whatever deals with the Russia's who
cares about that it has no relevance to
the situation unless there's some tie
that proves that this put a handle on
later candidate and now President Trump
it's all you know it's it's a very
bizarre it reminds me very much of the
weapons of mass destruction before Iraq
before the war in Iraq everybody
believed it because that's what the New
York Times and the major media told them
it's even worse now all right David let
me ask you a question and I realized
that of course is this question doesn't
really strike at the heart of what
you've been arguing but it's still
something that's on my mind and I just
like to know your thoughts on it there
are some of us out there who were
concerned regardless of the merits of
the case in fact let's assume for the
sake of argument wishes were set aside
the merits of the case there are people
we believe that there are a lot of
influential folks who seem to want to
prevent some kind of date on tour
reconciliation between the United States
and Russia and some of those people I
think
don't really know that many of the
details are pushing like the sort of
people you would encounter in the in the
press or on social media are pushing the
Russia gates story because they think
it'll throw a monkey wrench in the works
to make it more difficult for Trump to
try to negotiate better relations with
Russia now my primary issue when I think
about political candidates and politics
my primary issue is war and peace I
think we've had way too much war I think
almost all the war has been based on
propaganda and I think I've been
vindicated time after time and it's my
concern that this momentum is being used
to tie Trump's hands to make it harder
to do what he may want to do I suppose
which is to bring about better relations
with Russia what do you that that
regardless of the merits of the case
maybe that maybe your site is completely
correct or your suspicions are entirely
warranted but is there at least a
concern that unfortunately it seems to
play into the hands of some really bad
dudes if I may put it that way if you're
asking me whether I am in any way
supportive of choosing to have poor
relations with a country when that's not
what the facts dictate we should have
the answer is of course not if the
question is do I think that there are
individuals who are acting in bad faith
when it comes to from Russia I think the
answer is absolutely yes two people on
both sides of the political aisle and we
don't have time to really delve into the
details as to why so I don't and and
whether I you know have a particular
opinion as to what any individual has as
a motive
for talking about Trump Russia I can
only speak to my motives and they don't
fall under the umbrella of what you're
describing all right we are we've gone
longer than I am and I just make one
short comment if it's under a minute yes
okay both sides of the aisle I have to
really clarify that in the intelligence
analysis profession not intelligence
operations but intelligence analysis
there's no Eyal
this may sound sort of obsolete or
outdated but we we seek the truth and
you know it's very embarrassing for me
to be being accused of either a poutine
or a pump or a Trump apology apologist
because I think Trump is the very worst
president we ever had I have nine Grail
children they're not gonna have clean
air to breathe when they get to be my
age this is serious okay but I don't
want Trump to be accused falsely of
doing something that he didn't do call
me you know call me nostalgic or
something but I seek the truth there's
lots of reasons to impeach this guy to
get rid of them but not because of this
drummed up story to explain largely why
Hillary Clinton lost the election all
right now I've as I said I probably kept
you guys more than I said I would and so
I don't want to trespass too much
further on your time
but I do want to give each of it and on
this I'm gonna be a real stickler I'm
going to have a clock I'm gonna give
each of you three minutes to wrap up
what you want people to think about as
we conclude today so David we'll start
with you yeah I don't I don't need nor
do I even have the full three minutes I
do have to get to produce my show I
think the only thing that in the context
of this interview I would say is when
you listen to the interview and if you
have to go back and listen to it again
explore whether any of my assertions
were actually rebutted by anything Ray
said on a lot of the issues you'll see
that they were not on the ones where it
sounds like they were just google the
issue before you make a decision okay so
ray you've got three minutes to wrap up
from your sign
sure well Tom I guess I would just say
that we need to be fact-based here when
David says you know Google the answers
well you know people need to be to
realize that if they google the answers
they're not going to come of course the
things I said it'll all be from the New
York Times and The Wall Street Journal
Washington Post so the question is that
I would request that listeners listen
think about was number one when there's
an allegation
about mana for a page or whatever what
what does it have to do with whether
Trump and his campaign colluded with
Russia that's one of the big things here
okay
most of this stuff has no remote unless
you get a like a guy like manna fort who
seems to be a crook from the from the
day one guilty of all kinds of
money-laundering and everything else and
you know the tactic there is for Muller
to get get him aside and say look you
know if you tell us about Russian
collusion
you know you might we'll let you off
with less than your that we could get
you for so the whole thing is is a
construct initially begun when Hillary
Clinton thought that she could win the
election by criticizing Trump for being
open to dealing with the Russians and
then for a very very successful attempt
to disguise what happened with respect
to WikiLeaks revelations about how she
and her campaign witnessed the fact that
the top five people that the DNC quit on
the spot colluded to make sure that
Bernie Sanders would not win now now
Bernie Sanders in my view would would
have been a shoo-in over Donald Trump
and so these things are consequential
and when I say when I say that Bernie
Sanders would have been better than
Donald Trump has needed to to indicate
that and so one has to go back to the
beginning where these charges originated
the purpose for which they were
manufactured how the intelligence people
helped the DNC do this and I just say
stay tuned because if we can believe
newness who is the head of the House
Intelligence Committee
he's got the documents and what we see
in commis book and what we see in a lot
of the defense kind of stuff from the
FBI and the DOJ is sort of a priam
the attack to pour doubt on the
documents that newness says he has and
some of which he has already referred to
the Department of Justice for
prosecution of the deputy director of
SIA of FBI James Comey deputy McCabe so
there's a lot here and my my sorrow is
simply this that when I think back that
how we try to educate the American
people to the fact that there were no
weapons of mass destruction and that the
charges that Saddam Hussein was in touch
with al-qaeda were spurious and
ridiculous on their face we could not
get into the major media can we get in
the major media now we can not only not
get into the major media thumb we can't
get on Amy Goodman for God's sake so
even the alternative media doesn't want
to hear that there's some real doubt as
to whether direct Trump that colluded
with the Russians there's not only real
doubt there's no evidence that was the
case all right well my thanks to both of
you gentlemen David and Ray for your
time today you're both in very generous
and we appreciate it thank you most
welcome
I appreciate it thank you